[Music]
many great things come into your life
because you've had this success with
with Downton Abbey and then of course
there's the inevitable possibly downside
which is the porn parody that's out
there that they're mark I know you're
aware of this but you were like fine
with us talking about it but check this
out it's called this is real by the way
you do we think this up and what an
amazing show we have it's called
down on Abbey and I I don't I'm trusting
you haven't seen it I have not seen it
is that that's me isn't it the one with
the large breasts this is you I believe
right here yeah no it's not you I'm
saying what is your what is that
something that that you guys whole look
at that with a sense of humor yeah yeah
and it's endless the amount of space
that you know have become of the show
you know Peter he doing he did he did a
very funny for Funny or Die where he put
himself into scenes and he's calling it
Downton Abbey yeah and just keeps
announcing himself as the new owner and
know pretty much everyone's ignoring him
yeah yeah and you said we were doing the
break also you said that the reaction in
America has been more intense it's
definitely it is in the UK do you think
in England you think that's because
people in England like to downplay
things a little bit completely yeah yeah
Americans just have you know there's
there's a sort of more of an excitement
about it and it's a stranger to us we've
always liked to we like to act like well
we don't have that kind of we don't need
you know we're we're Americans we don't
need giant fashions and and and butlers
but then there's this secret part of it
that's like wouldn't that be cool yeah
and people actually think we live like
that we all do think you live we and we
live in the house yeah we think that's a
middle-class home in England let's talk
about non stop you play a flight
attendant and this film and you're
playing opposite the great Liam Neeson
and you had to undergo real training we
yes we did yeah we had a flight
attendant from Delta called Debbie who
we named Debbie Delta mhm and she she
took us through you know very basic
training
and we had to do training on the slides
you know the big inflatable slides and I
was terrified and I was doing that thing
of going oh I can't do this I'm wearing
heels and surely the heel will go
through the slide and it will be a
nightmare so I'm not doing it kept
making excuses and jamming the director
was going Michelle you know we really
need you to do it because if we need it
in the film so me and Lupita Nyong'o who
plays the other flight attendant were
terrified stood up there and you have to
do that thing where you you leap as you
go down and it goes it's terrifying so I
had to be the first to go down because
I'm head flight attendant and I
basically catch everyone else as they
come down so I slide down and it was the
best feeling it was like being eight
years old again I was like Oh got you
that's so strange to think of if a plane
had to have that kind of landing and
they said everybody off and they played
the slide and everyone went having to
stop ourselves yeah and smile we have to
look terrified and it would be like I
want to go again yeah every time they
were saying you know and cut and we were
waiting for the moment for them to go
and we've got to go again we were like
yeah just play on this for a while I do
remember when I watched the because I do
I'm one of the guys that pays attention
during the safety demonstrate don't they
say kick your shoes off first
yeah yes they they do and actually we
did we went down in flat shoes and you
don't actually I don't think you see
that in the field right I just want to
get the correct information out there
that's the kind of guy I am